BRET, SUNDAY, FINALLY THINGS
IMPROVE ACROSS MUCH OF THE
NORTHEAST.
>> Bret: GOOD TO HEERKS
RICK.
THANK YOU.
>> Bret: FEDERAL AGENTS
GOING AFTER EMPLOYERS WHO
MAY BE USING ILLEGAL
WORKERS.
YIELDING BIG RESULTS AND AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE BIG
COMPLAINTS, TOO.
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK
CORRESPONDENT HILLARY VAUGHN
IS HERE TONIGHT WITH THE
STORY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU FOR --
>> U.S. IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT AGENTS
ARE TARGETING BUSINESSES
MORE THAN EVER IN 2018.
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
HOMELAND SECURITY
INVESTIGATIONS MATTHEW ALLEN
SAYS THEY HAVE A DIRECTIVE
STRAIGHT FROM THE PRESIDENT
TO RAMP UP WORK SIGHT FORCES
LIKE THIS ONE CATCH
BUSINESSES COMPLETELY OFF
GUARD AND AUDIT EVERY WORKER
ON THE PAYROLL.
>> IF YOU ARE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION TO YOUR WORKFORCE
AND MAKING SURE YOU HAVE A
LAWFUL AND LEGAL WORKFORCE,
YOU SHOULD BE CONCERNED THAT
HSI COULD SHOW UP ON YOUR
DOORSTEP.
THAT'S NOT HEALTHY FOR
BUSINESS.
>> ALLEN SAYS AUDITS LIKE
THESE ARE A LYNCH PINEL IN
STRATEGY TO CRACK DOWN ON
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION BECAUSE
IT WORKS.
>> IN 2017, HSI CONDUCTED
ABOUT 1700 AUDITS OF
COMPANIES.
I THINK YOU CAN EXPECT US TO
ALMOST QUADRUPLE THAT.
>> COLLECTED OVER
$97 MILLION IN ASSETS AND
FINES FROM COMPANIES THAT
VIOLATED FEDERAL LABOR LAWS.
ONE OF THOSE COMPANIES PAID
$15 MILLION TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE BIGGEST FINE EVER LEVIED
FROM ONE OF THESE AUDITS.
ALLEN SAYS THESE TOTALS
COULD HIT NEW HIGHS IN 2018.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ICE THAT'S
TURNING UP OUT HEAT ON
EMPLOYERS.
NEW CALIFORNIA LAWS ARE
PUTTING BUSINESSES IN THE
MIDDLE OF A POLITICAL FIGHT
WITH D.C.
THREATENING THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FINES IF
COMPANIES COOPERATE WITH
AGENTS WITHOUT SEEING A
SIGNED WARRANT FIRST.
AND THAT SPARKSD CONFUSION
AMONG SOME CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES.
>> IF SOMEBODY JUST SHOW UP
AND KNOCK ON THE DOOR, BUT
IF THAT'S THE LAW, IF THAT
IS THE COMPLIANCE, I HAVE
NO -- NO IDEAS WHAT TO DO.
>> ALLEN SAYS WHILE
SANCTUARY CITY LAWS MAY TRY
TO SHIELD ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
FROM DEPORTATION EMPLOYERS
ARE NOT OFF THE HOOK.
>> NO EMPLOYER SHOULD
BELIEVE THEY HAVE ANY
PROTECTION OR SAFE HARBOR
FROM HSI WORKSITE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IF THEY
OPERATE A BUSINESS IN WHAT
THEY OR ANYBODY ELSE
INTERPRETS TO BE A SANCTUARY
CITY.
>> A LOT OF TIPS GET FROM
BUSINESS OWNERS THEMSELVES
WHO ARE WRATH OUT THEIR